Pont amiatt, mert volt az a kép, vagy
van az a kép, amikor Mózes az égő csipke
bokor előtt leveti a saruját és
letérdel, és a a az ember helye a szent
előtt az ad térdén van, és hogy ezt de
úgy úgy nehéz volt elképzelni, hogy azon
a kemény macskaköves
járdán, hogy hogyan fognak letérdelni az
emberek, meg lesznek idősebbek is,
lesznek fiatalok is, de úgy na volt
bennem egy izgalom, és teljesen
megdöbbentő volt számomra, hogy azt a a
20-30 percet, amit amíg a szentség
imádás tartott, mindenki letérdelt. És
olyan megható volt látni, hogy sokszor
olyan emberek, tehát hogy utólag látom
felvételeken, mert ott a a színpadnál
azért nem láttam annyi embert. De hogy
voltak idősebbek is, akiknek igazán
nehezére esett
letérdelni, és minden indokuk meglett
volna, hogy ne térdeljenek le,
és nagyon felemelő volt számomra látni
ezt ezt az elcsendesedést, ezt a a a
méltó helyünket megkapni a térdünk.
เ